we have a tweet from the man himself
Sean Strickland who has been lighting up
the internet as he's preparing for his
fight at UFC 297 this Saturday super
excited everybody should be watching
this fight it's going to be amazing I'm
it's going to be a lot of fun I'm very
excited he said hate speech isn't real I
didn't know I was fighting in North
Korea and he posted this video Shawn is
for the people oh man you got to hear
this but when have you ever seen a UFC
champion George sh Pier anybody else
stick up for you guys I
do it I do it I am not chasing the
Chinese check mark of Nike I don't give
a about that I care about you guys I
care about you guys being free I care
about you guys having freedom of speech
I give a about you guys I'll tell
you what you guys are awesome
and I cannot wait me this man go
to war for you
guys let's go no they're cheering he's
wearing a shirt it's got the Canadian
maple leaf says Strickland and says make
Canada great again this guy's a warrior
man this is u i see a lot of people
posting after his previous comments this
is how you push back on the machine he's
the big ask he is the pendulum swing and
uh it's epic so I say we should be
supporting him and uh that does bring up
an interesting issue of uh Bud Light Bud
Light is about to is is on the on the
verge of collapse did you guys know this
yeah the strike you heard you heard
about the strike coming up no there's a
strike too yes yeah and uh someone even
super chated saying that uh earlier in
the show they said they they they work
at a budlight bottling plant and the
strike is absolutely going to happen
some reports are saying there will be no
beer on the Shelves come March you look
budl doesn't want to anheiser they don't
want to give people raises they don't
want to give them the guarantees they're
asking for they've abandoned the
negotiations I wonder why it is they're
backing away from uh uh uh the
negotiations could it be that they're
down 30% in sales I think it really
shows that conservative have buyin power
real true buying power at a level that
we haven't seen in a long time maybe
it's not so much the issue is
conservative anymore it's that regular
people stopped buying the product I
think that's a big part of it I think
there are people who are active in
politics and and took part in the
boycott because they they believe in it
and they got caught in movement but I
think there were a lot of people who
just said like this is going too far and
I don't like it anymore just the most
well the most standard American right
the standard American and I think that's
almost more impressive because they're
harder to reach I mean this is what any
kind of political strategist will tell
you trying to get someone who's not that
engaged who's moderate to go out to the
polls is is impossible but they're all
voting with their dollar this way and
it's not necessarily for party it's
against ideology and I find that really
kind of inspirational going to the next
year yeah it's it's GNA be wild if
there's no Bud Light come March like the
the strike happens and dude you combine
the boycott you right now with with what
everything Sean Strickland is saying Bud
light's in the hot hot seat because
you've got you know pink news running
these these articles saying that he
called trans people in infection which
he didn't but he said I'll tell you
about budlight budl light's going to
have to say something that but I think
the woke left are going to try
everything in their power to avoid this
fight but more importantly you combine
the drop in sales with the workers being
upset they're not making enough money
not getting the guarantees they want
they stop making the beer what happens
if they stop making the beer nobody's
buying the beer what happens if no one
no one buys the beer you stop making the
beer yeah so wow then the strike would
be the final nail in the coffin could
you imagine if budlight just went belly
up that would be crazy I will I will I
will and it would be all from Dylan
milany I me I will say this an old
historic American company I mean that's
really fascinating well isn't it owned
by isn't it owned by anheiser it's
anheiser Bush right anheiser bush is
like it's all based in St Louis if but
it's I think goes as a brand goes
completely under I I I'll make this
broad I'll make this
broad if budlight as a brand I don't
think anzer Bush but budlight goes belly
up and they're just out like like the
budlight brand is done or in a much
broader sense if budlight drops off as a
major a major brand such though that it
appears more like an ancillary brand no
one really pays attention to I'm being
very broad with this to mean like if
budlight is wiped out of the top Market
I will write a check for
$110,000 to the charity of Matt Walsh's
choice for telling me I was wrong on my
Bud Light boycot position so if so
because look the strike that's happening
now I believe is a product of the
boycott people aren't getting paid
enough they're getting angry they're not
getting paid enough budlike can't pay
them more ditches the negotiating table
and and they're probably saying we can't
pay people more sales are down 30% and
the employees are like then we're going
to go on strike there's a possibility
they just go you know what bud light's
dead and if that
happens okay I will I will write I will
write a check to a charity of Matt
Walsh's Choice shout out Matt Walsh he's
like no boycott still on my point was we
should declare Victory and put pressure
on budlight to adhere to our worldview
and our framing of the things I still
think that's true like with Sean
Strickland coming out and saying these
things my point is to clap and cheer for
budlight saying thank you budlight for
sponsoring UFC and and Sean Strickland's
message to force them to publicly speak
either in favor or against it once again
creating a ripple effect in the boycut
now that being said if all we had to do
was sit back and just completely ignore
them and that would result in the
Cascade effect of a strike and then a
collapse I will admit I'm wrong and I
will uh make a donation to a charity of
Matt Walsh's Choice what about if it
goes Belly Up what would other companies
do would they be afraid to insert woke
you know marketing into maybe we'd get
some of those old 80s beer commercials
back where to what it was yeah they're
like on the river there's a boat
everyone's wearing shorts I don't know
if you guys saw about in November
Victoria Secret made a huge announcement
they were going back traditional yeah
right no one wanted to buy lingerie
after seeing it on a bunch of did you
did you hear about uh who would have
imagined that did you hear about the uh
the smokeless Snoop thing I tweeted
about this the Snoop Dog campaign to
smell the smell sell the fire pits
failed and apparently the CEO got
removed or whatever
let me just explain something to you
guys the idea that you would hire Snoop
Dog to sell outdoor equipment is the
stupidest thing I ever it was horrible
it horrible it was horrible because of
the engagement it took over the internet
in terms of sales and engagement it just
felt and I think the main problem is
they Mass promoted a product that cost a
lot of money I mean that product is like
it's it's it's not just that it's like
Snoop his fans do not buy camping
equipment hold on hold on I'm sure he's
got a lot of fans by cam equipment but
no they do not you want like be grills
to be announcing this because everybody
watches like I want one of those it's
not like target market yeah it's not
like the big um they had those lighters
that had the like extended uh flame and
it was uh Snoop Dogg and Martha Stewart
that that was like their they did this
like commercial pairing and he was
selling them and she's like you can
light candles and he's like or something
else it was perfect he collaborated with
her it was still a collaboration they
like had a show they were like hanging
out for a minute so I I bring this up
because Victoria Secret is like we're
going to sell lingerie using big fat
models and ugly women and then all of a
sudden nobody wanted to buy their
products anymore and it's because women
and men want to look at attractive
models and think I can be like that if I
buy this product that's why you buy
that's why you buy stuff you buy stuff
because you're like oh I want I mean
they already did that the advertising
companies already told us when you buy
our product you have access to this
lifestyle and no one wants access access
to the lifestyle of being unable to get
off your couch cuz your butt's too big
but but it's not that like Victoria's
Secret in particular right you've got
all these big fat models and ugly women
and the average woman who Megan Meg rapo
too right so yes so first the woman who
is buying Victoria Secret I imagine I
could be wrong but I imagine is thinking
I want to be attractive to my my husband
to my significant other here's this
beautiful woman she looks at that and
says wow I could look like her if I buy
thater or whatever and then she buys it
the man sees that woman and goes yeah my
wife could look like that I'm going to
buy it then you put a big fat woman on
the on the on the wall and the regular
one looks at it and says I don't want to
look like that actually go ahead I was
going to say the they it's Beyond lre
they'll use you know all kinds of models
whatever and I'm not always against this
but the thing is if you're looking at an
ad and something doesn't look good on
someone whether it be lingerie or a
shirt or a skirt I'm not going to buy it
because it doesn't look good it's like
selling it's like selling Viagra and
having the models being depressed you
know they're always super happy like
extremely excited they're having a bad
time you're like no thank you there's a
thing too where when you're buying
clothes online you can check and see and
it will show you a model who's wearing
any of the sizes right and the further
you go up you're like oh if I have to
buy that size I'm not buying this cuz
that looks terrible you know no for sure
I mean there it almost Works true the
consumer's favor being like maybe I
should just skip buying I prob looks
good in my closet right now man I'll be
really excited if bud goes on strike and
they just don't make any they just tank
yeah because look I I talked about
Fusion quite a bit I mentioned this even
like last week I think I mentioned the
other other day I had a friend worked at
Fusion which is the ABC News Univision
joint venture all operating on
investment yeah this is like last night
and they were announcing negotiations to
unionize and I told my friend you'll get
fired in two seconds cuz your company
does not make money the moment you walk
up to the president and say all 300
employ employees want a 10% raise he's
going to say You're Fired I'm shutting
the company down cuz you don't make
money these people at budlight who are
like we're going to go on strike the
boss is going you guys are not selling
any product okay we are down 30% we're
not giving you more money and if they
say then we won't make any beer then
they'll like okay well then we're done
that's the end I don't I can't imagine
they would want to abandon budlight as a
as a brand because it's such a like a
long-standing iconic product but at this
point I kind of think it's entirely
possible with the upcoming strike the
perfect storm hits and they just say
it's going to cost us $20 million to try
and recover the lost product from the
strike the brand is already down 30%
it's being mocked relentlessly we're not
getting our customers back just stop the
bleed stop throwing good money at bad
it's imagine being that marketing
manager who pulled the Dyan mlan St and
then got fired she's never going to get
a job again oh they're going to she's
going to be in marketing like like
college courses yeah yeah the great
failure the great failure because she
clearly didn't have an understanding of
the brand at all there's that Quiznos
commercial that no one ever forgot of
the weird chinchilla things
screeching and they they you never you
might be a little too young and I was
like Amish I was not allowed to watch TV
growing up I'll pull it up Quiznos I
wasn't actually Amish for clarification
I just had strict parents I bet all I
have to do is search for Quizno's
commercial sponge monkeys here look look
at this this thing right here we love
what
yes that's MUSC subc conscious they to
us no
sub this is incredible they are crunchy
they are because they
them okay well this was make advertising
great again I mean this is just great
wild was a massively successful
advertising campaign and they teach
about it in marketing courses as to why
it worked why was so good why everyone
loved it and I think you know who they
really hit with this midnight Stoners
hungry and they're like man and they're
just staring at her like what but the
real is children children saw this and
were like hilarious let's go it's a lot
it's a lot it's that they no one would
forget it you watch it and you're like
what the did I just watch they used to
do this thing back in the day where in
magazines there's like a famous example
of of what they would do with with ads
is a a woman a like a teenage girl in a
swing and she has three legs one two
legs are going forward and there's a
third leg going backwards creepy they
would do a ton of things like this so
that when you were flipping through it
would catch your attention oh like Do
Double Take and look at it longer yep
and so this is exactly that so you know
with budl maybe maybe they were like
remember the Quiznos creepy sponge
monkey things you're getting them way
too much credit no no hold on hear me
out someone that lady she publicly she
goes we want diversity in Bud Light
Behind the Scenes she's like remember
that creepy weird thing Quiznos did
let's hire Dylan Mulaney oh man
chinchilla may maybe they were thinking
that creating some kind of shock content
would generate massive buzz and
attention to create I I I bet they were
thinking controversy good I feel like
they just took their their core audience
for or their core consumers for granted
they said we can do whatever and they'll
buy it no matter what so we might as
well just push to get a really
Progressive audience in here didn't that
start like in February uh did Mo thing
is reaching yeah if it did that really
should show the people that it only
takes about 12 months no matter how
powerful brand is if them really like
getting their pockets hit it takes a
real toll the M mulany was already very
distasteful to a lot of people at the
time yeah was he ended up with uh I
think it was around February like uh
mulany ended up at the White House
talking to Joe Biden about how important
it is to make sex changes for kids worse
ER why are you talking about this like
you want the guy who's pushing for kids
to have sex changes to push your to like
boost your beer that doesn't make any
sense it's super weird and I think even
people who a lot of beer drinkers want
grandkids you know they don't a lot of
them do it's one of their main concerns
I open a beer and they're like but when
am I have a grand that's what I do
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at
timcast.net exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next
time